عجلا ام اجلا سيكسر احد الطرفين الجمود في
الحرب اشد المراحل لم تاتي بعض والمعركه
الكبرى يبدو انها ستكون في الربيع او حتى
قبل ذلك ليس تحليلا وانما حديث الجندي
الاوكراني بالتالي وهو رقيب في لواء موشاه
56 القريب من ذا بروسيا وماريو بول السؤال
الذي اقترحه بالتالي ولم يجب عليه هو من
سيضرب اولا واين سنحاول نحن في الساعه
ستون ملاحقه الاجابه بعد قليل لكن من اجل
هذه المعارك المتوقعه ماذا تكرهني ام
مسلحه مثل دول النيترو وان لم تنضم للحلف
للمساعدات منيات المليارات اكثر من 27
مليارا و800 مليون دولار من امريكا واكثر
من ثلاثه مليارات مئه مليون دولار من
اوروبا تتحدث هنا عن المساعدات العسكريه
فقط والمعضله في التدريب الضابط السابق في
الجيش الب ان هي نيكالاس دونمون يقول ان
الدعم بالدبابات مهم لكن الاكثر اهميه هو
القدره على تدريب جنود اوكرانيا عليها
المانيا التي وافقت على تسليم الاكياف
دبابات ليفارد اثنين بدات بالفعل استقبال
جنود اوكرانيين للتدريب على مركبات من
طراز ماردير التي اعلنت ارسال 40 منها الى
اوكرانيا هذا التدريب سيقام في مدينه
مونستر
وسيكملوا بحلول نهايه مارس بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الالمانيه وفي مقابل ذلك روسيا
ليست صامطه
تخططوا لي تعزيز نظام الدفاع الجوي في
مناطق العمليه العسكريه بمنظومه
الجديده خطته روسيا قد تفاجئوا اوكرانيا
وسنتحدث عن تفاصيلها لاحقا كيف تريد
الاستعداد ولذلك ورجم هذا الدعم الكبير
تريد المزيد من دبابات ابرامز وليبعاد
اثنين وهتشالنجر الحديث مات يدور الان عن
الطائرات المقاتله ووزير الدفاع الالماني
في مقابله مع صحيفه صوت دوتش تسايتون
استبعد هذا الامر والسبب من وجهه نظرها ان
الطائره المقاتله هي انظمه اكثر تعقيدا
بكثير من الدبابات واعتبر ارسالها الان
مؤامره كبيره و رغم ان الدبابات اقل
تعقيدا سيستغرق التدريب عليها وقتا طويلا
فماذا عن الاكثر تعقيدا المتحدث باسم
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه يوري ايه هناك
اشاره الى ان المده المتوقع لتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على اف 16 مثلا
ستكون سته اشهر الحرب في البر في الجو وفي
البحر ايضا هي حرب مجموعات صغيره من
القوات الخاصه علمتني قوارب وذلك حسب
وهو رئيس وحده الاستخبارات والمراقبه
والاستطلاع على الجبهه الجنوبيه
الاوكرانيه
تعمل كياب على تطوير قواتنا خاصه برمائيه
وفي هذه النقطه واشنطن قدمت لها الزوارق
دوريه نهريه يمكن ان تستخدمها في غارات
عبر نهر النيلرو
[موسيقى]